여러분들 아마 기억하실지 모르겠는데
제가 3년 전에 건물을 사
드리겠습니다 건물을 착공해서 이제
공사하고 있어요
그 사람입니다 제가 오늘은 여러분들
아마 기억하실지 모르겠는데 제가 3년
전에 구독자 분들 중에 강남빌딩을
매입해주겠다 해서
명칭이
강남
프로젝트였는데
정말 오랜 시간이 걸렸어요
하는데도 1년이 넘게 걸렸고
계약하고 건물을 멸시하는데도 시간이
좀 오래 걸렸고 건물을 착공해서 이제
공사하고 있어요 거의 한 3년과
같습니다 저희가 설계를 2021년도에
제가 2탄도 하고 싶고 3탄도 하고
싶지만 일단 1탄이 좀 마무리됩니다
다음에 이제 다음편 찍으려고
했는데 이렇게 오래 걸릴지 몰랐어요
지금 그 프로젝트가 이번에 좀 착공을
하게 돼서
어떤 상태까지 지금 진행이 됐는지
여러분들한테 좀 설명을 해 드리려고
합니다 설계를 좀 어떻게 좀
진행하셨는지 설명해 주시면 좋을 것
같습니다 돼지가 이제
3종일반주거지역이었어요 그래서 건폐율
50% 용적률 250% 제한 지역인데
다행히 이제 북측의 도로가 있어서
기초사선에 대한 완화를 받을 수
있었고 그랬기 때문에
용적률을 250%까지 다
확보할 수가 있었습니다
삼정이 보통 250% 받는 건물이 좀
생각보다 많이 없어요 거의 다
200% 초반대
그런 정도 받는 경우 많은데이 땅은
짓기에는 너무 좋은 땅이었죠 거기에
또 다른 이점이 있었던 것이 이제
경사진형이라서 전면도로
쪽이 경사가 아니라 측면도로 쪽이
경사에서
지하 1층에 노출되는 그런 장점이
있었습니다 그래서 전면 도로에서는
바로 지하 1층 진입이 가능했고
측면으로 이제
지상 1층
진입이 가능하게끔 그렇게 설계를 할
수 있었어요
총 규모는 어떻게 되지 대지면적이 약
55평 정도 되고 전체 건물의 규모는
지하 2층에 지상 5층
연면적이 한 200평 정도 되는 그런
질문입니다 최상층은 지붕이 일부
경사지분이 좀 들어가긴 하는데 그건
좀 디자인적으로
계
풀어봤습니다
외장재나 이렇게 디자인은 좀 어떻게
디자인 같은 경우에는
여러가지를 제안을 사실 많이
드렸었어요 그래서
디자인에 대한 방향도 저희가
계획을 하면서 다 노출이 되는 커튼을
타입도 있었고 아니면 좀
폐쇄적으로 해서 내부의 개방성을
확보하는 그런
타입의 디자인도 있었고
적절하게 창이랑 벌금 섞어서
그렇게 조율을 했던 디자인도 있었는데
최종적으로는 이제 모노타일 벽돌
타일을 사용한 건물의 디자인을 선택이
됐고요
전반적으로 이거를 한 톤의 색감으로
계획을 할지 아니면 좀 톤을 분리를
해서 아무리 분자에 보이게끔
나눠줄지를 고민을 하다가 한 가지
색상으로 좀 통일을 시켜서
커 보이는 효과를 줄 수 있도록
그렇게 반영을 했습니다 공사는 아마
이제 매년
상반기쯤에 아마 마무리가 될 것
같아요
6개월 정도 설계기간 걸렸고 그리고
공사 기간은 한 거의 한 1년 정도
소요됐다고 보시면 될 거 같고
지하만 완성되었을
예상하셔야 되고요 그리고 저희가
설계를 하고
난 후에 바로 공사를 시작한게 아니라
1년 정도에
텀이 있었잖아요 그 사이에 공사비가
만나고 있습니다
그래서 저희가 실시설계로 완료하고
바로 공사비에 대한 부분을
견적을 받았었는데 저희가 많이 증가를
했습니다 제가 봤을 때는
앞으로 공사비가 더 떨어지거나 뭐
그럴 거 같진 않아요 그래서 만약에
여러분들도 좀 설계를 하게 된다면
내가 그 설계했던 시기랑 공사했던
시기랑 만약에 텀이 좀 있으면
공사비가 조금 달라질 수도 있다라는
것 좀 알고 계시면 좋을 것 같고
그래서 일단은 현장 가서 좀 어떻게
지금 현재 공자 상황인지 한번 좀
보도록 하시죠
근데 지금 현장에 와 있는데 일단은이
건물 위치가 너무 좋아요네 지금
강남역에서
도보로 이동할 만한 거리에 위치하고
있고 그리고 대로 바로이면 코너에
있거든요 그리고이 건물 앞에 도로가
12미터 정도 됩니다 그래서 이쪽으로
좀 더 가면은 도로가 좀 줄어들긴
하는데이 건물까지는 너무 좋아요
그리고 무엇보다 일조권 사선도 제일
잘 받지 않는 그렇게 불쾌한
건물이라고 보시면 될 거 같은데 저도
이제 신축공사를
해봤지만이 정도 지하 파는 데까지
일단 너무 오랜 시간이 걸리죠 근데
이제 지하랑 1층 정도만 완성되면
위에 올라가는 건 금방 올라가서 지금
일단은
초기 단계라고 보시면 될 거 같은데
제가이 건물 같은 경우에는 계속 이제
짓고 있는 스토리나 이런
현장 같은 거를 계속 좀 촬영할
예정이니까
계속 좀 지켜보시면 좋을 것 같습니다
건물이 일단은 그 5층으로 완성되면은
아마 진짜
엄청 높을 거 같은데 아까 말씀하신
것처럼 6층 높이의 건물처럼 보일
거예요
근데 이제 최상층의 높이가 조금 더
높기 때문에 좀 더 커 보이는 효과가
있을 겁니다 몇 미터 정도 될까요
전면에서
봤을 때 그 정도의 높이가 나올
거예요 일단 지하 공사하는 것 좀
알려주시겠어요 저희가 서울시 같은
경우에는
지하 승마기 공사를 하는 공법을 좀
제한을 둬요 그래서 저희도 CIP
공법이라고 해서
철골 기둥을 중간중간에 설치를 하고
콘크리트를 부어서 원형 기둥을
만들어서 주변에 막아주는 그런 방식의
흑막이 공법이 적용이 되어 있습니다
그리고 흙막이를 시공한 다음에
가시설이라 그래서 지금 보시면은
이렇게 철골들이
걸려 있죠
가시설이기 때문에
추후에 이제 지하 외벽이 시공이 되고
나면 다 철거를 할 거예요 그런
질문일 수도 있는데 보통 여기까지
하는 비용량 어느 정도 들어갈까요
지하층 토목공사 하는데 있어서 지금
말씀드린 흑막이 그다음에 이제
불착하죠 그
다음에 그 가시설 설치하는데 저희
현장 같은 경우 예를 들면 최소 3
4억원 정도 3 4억 정도
지상층 올리는 것보다 대량 한 2배
정도 더 들고 공사기간도 어떻게 보면
2배 정도 더 늘리잖아요 그래서
만약에 뭐 여러분들이 지하를 파시거나
하실 때 뭐 이런 점들을 좀 참고해서
하시면 좋을 것 같고 그리고 앞으로이
지금 강남 프로젝트 저희 이제
1호입니다 이거네 그래서 이게 지금
어떻게 변할지 어떤 임차인이
맞춰질지를 제가 이제 유튜브에 계속
올릴 예정이니까
지켜봐 주시면 좋을 것 같고네 오늘
영상은 여기까지 하고요 지금
강남 프로젝트 1호가 어떻게 바뀌는지
여러분들 지켜봐 주시면 좋을 것
같습니다 오늘 영상 여기까지
하겠습니다 감사합니다
[음악]